Normally, we think of using water to put out a fire.
But in this video, you'll learn how to use water to start them.
If you're ever lost in a survival situation, here's a little trick you're gonna be so glad to know.
To practice this technique, we'll use three sheets of paper and a water bottle.
Paper with black ink is easy to practice with.
So let's get started making this top sheet into a platform...
...by folding it in half three different ways.
The black ink is showing and that's a good thing.
So now, we can prepare these other two sheets by cutting or ripping them in half.
This gives us four pieces...
...and we can fold each of them in half so that they're creased down the middle.
All right, time for the action.
We'll need to remove the label from this little bottle...
...and use the convex edge as a makeshift magnifying glass to focus the sunlight.
It only takes a few seconds to get this paper smoking and pretty soon, we've got it smoldering.
When the hole is about the size of a quarter, we'll need to slowly add multiple layers of papers.
Swinging it around gently will help the air get to the embers...
...and when they get hot enough, a flame appears.
That's it in a nutshell, but in practice,...
...you'll probably find that it's not quite as easy as it looks.